[Music]
the 2021 state of devops report released
last year
it contained findings about how teams
navigate key areas of software delivery
we talked with one of the researchers
dustin smith about the report section on
team culture
what did this section of the report
focus on
we look at how team culture impacts a
team's ability to perform we've done
that for several years and as i had
mentioned
we look at a lot of factors and team
culture tends to be one that's really
important
because it has a direct connection to
performance both
for a team's ability to deliver software
quickly and reliably and
meet their profitability goals their
organizational goals
what separates elite teams from the rest
yeah when we look at good team culture
we use ron westrom's model of
organizational culture which has
essentially a taxonomy that runs the
gamut from a pathological team
that
you know blames people for making errors
all the way to bureaucratic
has a little more red tape set up within
it to a generative team culture which
is performance oriented it's highly
cooperative and a culture of no blame
right and so what what is a culture of
no blame look like
well
you have to be willing to give your
teams some room to make mistakes and
they have to feel like if they make a
mistake they're not going to be punished
for that
and
this creates a culture where you're more
reflective
where
you know that if you take a chance if
you take a risk
even if you fail you're still going to
learn from that and you'll be better the
next time you try something like that
and this creates a group of people that
then want to innovate more
and they're not afraid of doing so they
don't need to just stay within the rails
of how the team was originally designed
to operate and we find that teams that
are like that are higher performing
what is a generative team culture
generative team culture comes from ron
westrom's model of organizational
culture which runs from all the way to a
pathological team culture which
is
punishes kind of people for making
mistakes
to a bureaucratic team culture all the
way to a generative team culture which
focuses not on the mistakes but how you
can improve from the mistakes and how
best
to work together to improve over time
they're performance oriented they want
they see opportunities to get better and
capitalize on those things
what is the makeup of generative teams
what we find is that when teams are made
up of
a group of people that are diverse they
come from different backgrounds
and they feel like when they
bring up something from their expertise
when they have an opinion or an idea
that their team will be accepting of
that you know maybe not everyone will
agree on it but their opinion is valued
and there can be value taken from their
point
um
when teams feel like they can do this
they feel comfortable sharing ideas and
that they'll be supported by the people
around them they feel a part of that
group they're higher performing but
they're also less likely to experience
burnout as a result
how does team culture relate to burnout
so we use christine maslick's definition
of burnout for this report and we looked
at things like do you feel exhausted
when you're doing your work are you
bringing those negative feelings home
and
is that affecting your home life outside
of work are you able to actually
separate yourself from your work
are you starting to feel cynical about
that and we put all of that together
and
we look at which teams are experiencing
that and we find that teams with a good
team culture so are they generative
people feel like they belong do they
feel included are
half as likely to experience burnout and
why that's so important is that we're
going through a pandemic right now and a
lot of people are experiencing burnout
so what's the core idea of this section
of the report
i think
trying to motivate people to focus not
just on what are the technical practices
that need to be implemented on a team in
order to be successful but also look at
your people
over those things and focus on how can
we make our people feel more supported
how can they
take small risks how can they feel like
they can innovate focusing on those
things are a win for
employers for businesses because it like
i mentioned earlier reduces burnout
reduces attrition
all while increasing productivity and
organizational goals
where can you just go to learn more
that's a great question
for everything devops at google you can
go to cloud.google.com
there you can find the state of devops
2021 report
like i mentioned it's completely free
you just need to sign up you can
download the report
but there are also other assets there
like if you want to read about any of
these individual capabilities that we
mentioned here for example team culture
bernal we have specific articles written
about those topics and how you could
apply those practices
and finally we have the devops quick
check which also allows you to measure
your own performance a really five
question survey and get a rough idea of
how are you performing relative to the
industry
[Music]
you